okay here's are we going to do we'll
take my same favorite quadratic x
squared plus 5x plus 6 right but this
time i'm going to divide by something
that doesn't work okay that is going to
give me a remainder right so let's try
this process again and squared plus 5x
plus 6 I know it can divide by X plus 2
I know it can divide by X plus 3 what
would happen if I / x + line ok let's go
through this process here let's see if
you can capture the understated the
excess of the important parts right plus
1 matters but not as much so I say X how
many times can I go into x squared x
times what do I do with that X just like
before I multiply it down that gives me
x squared x so x times X is x squared x
times 1 is just plus X fantastic okay
what do I do with that now is the
subtraction step right just like I did
30 take away 28 just like an idea x
squared plus 5x take away x squared plus
2x you see why last time we were talking
about subtracting polynomials if thing
is in here right I just gave left with
4x right 4x ok I bring down this left
over 6 down here just like I do with my
normal numerical long division plus DS
and then I say how many x's go into 4x
four of them plus 4 ok now this step
will be slightly different I multiply
the fall back down 4x plus ok and now I
want to do my subtraction hey there's a
guy hanging around it it's not 0 it
doesn't divide through cleanly I have a
remainder of 2 okay and do you remember
when we broke this statement right 503
equals this times this plus this this
times this plus this let's see if it
works allegedly what I've got is this
times this
Plus this do you see that that's what
this is saying okay I can extend this
out these things up and toss one x+ for
my pair of numbers is one and four right
so I know there's an expert at the front
one plus four is equal to five and
that's why I have 5x + 1 times 4 is
equal to four so that's why I have for
their right you sure I done this reverse
this is factorizing in Reverse right
usually you're trying to think of a pair
of numbers but now you know what the
pair of numbers is so you just use them
okay and then I've got a to hang it on
the end well hold on matts x squared
plus 5x plus 6 just like we expected so
this process of long division here right
numerical long division polynomial long
division okay um it's not really that
complicated it's just this guy but it's
more out of track because I don't even
know what the numbers are but i can
still divide them right that's all power
of mathematics you can work with things
even when you don't know what they're
equal to and get results at the end
which are exactly right and you can
prove them okay so read the cushion with
me carefully and then you'll see what's
going on they say perform the following
divisions that division when they said
perform the division they mean do this
thing ok go through that process and
then write the first polynomial that
polynomial in the form and then this is
the form they're talking about right the
dividend is the thing you're actually
dividing on that's the dividend okay in
fact we can leave a label on here that's
the dividend ok that's the today the
device on the divisor is then you're
dividing by ok so that's this guy over
here this is the demise on ok that's the
divisor what you end up with is the
question ok so this is the results you
get at the end
question and then we already know when
there's a number hanging off the NT I
mean we have an are there that's the
remainder okay yes yes you absolutely
can in in this way yeah yes you can find
the remainder will be another fraction
if you're riding i'll show you after we
chances i'll show you the next step is i
can write in the video describing okay
alright so let's give it a shot Sally
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to write my big division symbol
it's going to be pretty big because I've
got to fit all of these terms underneath
it ok so I'm going to go to X cubed
minus x squared plus 5x plus 3 ok ok is
that right i've got an x + 6 here that's
my divisor dividend to buyers are now a
new start i'm going to work out the
question and they're made of ok my first
question is because it's all about the
x's in this important part how many exes
can I fit into 2x cubed and the answer
is like I'm just dividing our time like
this whole process about dividing so I
just divide this by this I can fit two x
squared number of X peas into to execute
ok and I will know that I have chosen
that right because when i multiply it
back down I should get the same thing
underneath 2x squared times X that's 2x
cubed but that's not all 2x squared x 6
e plus 12x squared ok hey go what I do
with this I'm to the subtraction step
our time ok be careful fierce I until
minus x squared and i'm going to
subtract 12x squared minus 1 minus 12
that's minus 13 right x squared ok top
down the subtraction what i do after the
subtraction good so i'm getting all of
these pairs of
right so that 5x he's going to climb
down and then I asked you how many exes
can I fit into minus 13x squared answer
minus 13x in fact these guys are PR
these days up here are just these guys
and you bring down the power once that's
all you're doing right at least if
you're divided by X peach time that's
all you so I put my money's 13x up there
what do I do with that guy I multiply it
back I multiplying back right so there's
my minus 13x squared out the front which
I'm supposed to get minus then see you
next time six ok they're not just
starting to get a bit large that's ok
that's all right 13 x 6 or 10 times 6 is
16 and 3 times 6 is 18 so that sounds
like 17 minus 70 80 k minus 78 x it's a
bit big but that's ok you couldn't do
calculator can crunch that part for you
if you like ok now i'm doing subtraction
right so i'm subtracting a negative
which means i am adding right so 5 plus
78 is 83 ok there's a term hanging out
on its own shouldn't be hanging out so
right bit lonely what am I going to do
bring down that plus 3 ok so a bit of a
friend plus 3 ok another all mr. my last
step 83 X how many times can eat and
connects go into that answer
eighty-three times ok and then i
multiply back 83 x ok some / typic
actually to do this 8 times 6 or 80
times 6 is 480 and then 3 times 6 is 18
what's that 496 196 I wanna check it one
only eight to eighty of course it plus
what are you okay and then i subtract
sanuk a deal right look all right that's
my roommate oh it's a big number they're
big numbers okay the reason every big
numbers is because I've got numbers in
here that build and build and build on
each other is this correct how do I know
okay well I can test it out I can test
it out fairly easily right divisor push
it remained our divisor quotient and
remainder can we give it a spin let's
try it out I'll give you a minute to get
a head start on meat and then I'll start
in the dark do you see what I've done I
did my arms I did my sneaky trick where
when I multiplied across I wrote them
underneath each other in such a way that
the right toes with the right powers
then line up with each other okay so you
can see I only have a single X cubed
term in there namely 2x cubed minus 13x
squared plus 12x squared that's minus X
square plus 83 take x 78 that's plus 5
and the 4 98 is what I get from here and
then there's the minus 45 hanging on the
end so I put him underneath so that they
all I'm up which on which is plus 3
which is exactly what we got ok I think
that is beautiful right I'm honestly
honestly this is the kind of answer
where am I really did I screw something
up did I get it did I get it wrong did I
mess up like we've done a lot of these
by hand like in our heads before we go
into a calculator but it's true it works
it works beautifully it nails it right
on the head so this is long division
next week we're going to have a look at
ways you can do this that are number one
in harder examples and number two ways
you can do it a little more efficiently
because even though it is beautiful it
still is very time-consuming can we do
better we can and i'll show you next
week